here are 8 movies that improve my life
and maybe they'll improve yours too
number one catch me if you can catch me
if you can as a 2002 film that is a true
story obviously there are probably some
dramatic elements and it stars Leo
DiCaprio and Tom Hanks directed by
Steven Spielberg it's an absolute
classic the film is based on the life of
Frank William abignale Jr one of the
most successful con men in American
history he effortlessly performed some
of the most depraved acts of deception
by posing as a Pan-American Airlines
pilot a doctor in Georgia and a
prosecutor in Louisiana all before his
19th birthday this guy was an absolute
Prodigy while I wouldn't recommend
living your life like Frank William
I don't want you to con people more than
you already do but what this movie
teaches you is an invaluable lesson
about how human psychology works people
know what you tell them Carl Catch Me If
You Can teaches you about the power of
presentation by the way you dress the
way you hold yourself you subconsciously
signal to people how they should treat
you do you carry yourself with dignity
confidence Authority if not what does
that tell other people about how they
should treat you it makes you wonder how
many people that you look up to in life
are actually full of totally faking it
they don't know anything but they dress
the part and have self-confidence and on
the flip side it makes you wonder how
many people genuinely know what they're
talking about have exceedingly valuable
information but have no presentation
skills whatsoever so you perceive
whatever they're saying negatively
presentation is an amplifier it will
amplify the good in you or the bad in
you and in this world tons of very bad
people have very high Charisma so if you
perceive yourself as a good person and
you have strong values I think it's a
moral imperative to also develop
Charisma to present your self and your
information well to combat the evil
charismatic people in the world it's
also just a fantastic film it's so easy
to watch so entertaining and you will
leave this film with some new ideas I'm
a celebrity Liberty in an emergency can
you catch me through on that line please
Groundhog Day Groundhog Day is a 1993
comedy starring Bill Murray the story
follows a weatherman who finds himself
reliving the same day over and over and
over again the thing I love about
Groundhog Day is that it's not only an
extremely easy film to watch it's also a
profound film about you and your own
mental prison that you can fall into if
you're not careful Groundhog Day is a
metaphor for the prison of the self Bill
Murray's character was self-serving and
he robbed himself of Joy because of it
every one of his days felt agonizingly
identical and he wasn't able to escape
it until he got outside of himself
because going outside of yourself
expands your world and adds meaning to
your life by watching Groundhog Day You
Will Be Inspired to do things you
haven't done before to escape the prison
of your mind and stop being so selfish
so self-serving so inside it'll also
inspire you to detox your soul from
irony poisoning
a thousand people
freezing their butts off waiting to
worship a rat it'll help you identify
that skepticism sarcasm pessimism these
things will eat you alive
okay campers
rise and shine
I've been doing a little research on
Aunt Helen's tumor and it's totally
clear that anybody with familial
abdominus palaposis should be
supplementing platinum-based doublet
regiments with icos and pentioic acid
Limitless everybody knows Limitless
Limitless is a 2011 film starring
Bradley Cooper and Robert De Niro it's
about a struggling writer who gains
access to a mysterious drug that
enhances his intellectual abilities to
superhuman levels but it also exposes
him to dangerous consequences I learned
to play the piano in three days
Limitless is not art I'll say it right
now but its impact on me was undeniable
I watched Limitless on a plane when I
was 15 years old and it blew my mind it
got me thinking about the brain I have
and how perhaps I'm not using it to its
full potential it got me thinking that
perhaps The Key to Greatness is already
within me everything that I have ever
learned is not forgotten but lying
dormant somewhere in my subconscious I I
just needed to find a way to access it
my brain was just pouring this stuff out
everything I'd ever read heard seen was
now organized and available here it is
here you go this movie naturally is
everybody's gateway drug into biohacking
and nootropics if you don't know what
nootropics are they're brain enhancing
supplements because when you watch a
movie about a guy who solves all of his
life problems by taking one mystery pill
gets you thinking about whether or not
this mystery pill exists in real life
okay so what do we have here some
unknown untested possibly Dangerous Drug
scammed out of some unidentified lab
somewhere given to me by a highly
unreliable guy I hadn't seen in years
so you want some more yes definitely
watching Limitless will inspire you to
use the brain you currently have to its
full potential it'll motivate you to
think about your problems differently
and ask the question if I were on nzt48
how would I solve this problem if you
haven't watched Limitless watch it
what
I want you to hit me as hard as you can
let me tell you a little bit about Tyler
Durden there's not really much I can say
about Fight Club that hasn't been said
in a billion he's literally me montages
or film analysis videos so I'm gonna
give you the overly simplistic take the
reason why you should watch it if you
want to improve your life is because of
an energy Fight Club represents an
energy a simple thought that of
embracing chaos most of the time it's
not the actual external events that
happen to you that will ruin your life
but it's your own fear of bad things
happening this constant rumination that
will rob you of Life your fear of death
will rob you of Life Fight Club will
remind you that the answer to your
life's problems isn't buying that new
piece of Ikea furniture it's not getting
a matching cutlery set it's not buying
that beautiful sexy 2023 Toyota Tundra
because it won't make you happy it's all
just stupid because in a way these are
all just ways to avoid death they're all
little consumeristic traps that are
basically a facade that Taps into your
instinct to self-preserve why do you
need a nice house why do you need a
matching cutlery set is that going to
keep you from dying is that going to
keep the chaos at Bay in your life by
watching Fight Club you will become
Bolder more willing to take risk it'll
really start to get you thinking maybe
discomfort not only isn't really that
bad but maybe it's exactly what I need
like a monkey ready to be shot into
space
watching Fight Club will also
permanently imprint the character of
Tyler Durden onto your brain so when
you're feeling a little too comfortable
you're afraid to ask a girl out you're
afraid to go for a run you can ask
yourself what would Tyler Durden do in
this situation once again not that Tyler
Durden is a shining example of how to
live your life
but just like Frank William Abigail Jr
movies can have caricatures of the
dramatic extreme end of certain
philosophies that you can borrow when
it's useful to you and then discard when
it's not tell you are by far the most
interesting single serving friend I've
ever met
to have this thing everything on a plane
is single serving even though I get it
it's very clever
how's that working out for you
what being clever anyways Watch Fight
Club definitely awesome yeah I mean if
it's too much trouble you totally don't
have to but if you need someone I mean
Duncan
yes there you go the way way back is an
underrated film not very many people
have heard of this it's a 2013 Coming of
Age comedy drama despite the fact that
it's fairly unknown it has some familiar
faces in there we have Steve Carell and
Sam Rockwell most notably Steve Carell
in this movie is an absolute he
is not even a little bit funny whereas
Sam Rockwell is very funny well actually
Sam Rockwell is always funny I'm gonna
have to ask you to leave
what yeah you're gonna have to take off
for getting complaints you're having way
too much fun it's making everyone
uncomfortable when you watch The Way Way
Back you just feel good and I think the
importance of that can't be understated
so much of what we soak in on social
media wastes your time and leaves you
with absolutely nothing but this film
kind of brightens up your mood and
inspires you to be a good person it
makes you really look up to Sam
Rockwell's character because Sam
Rockwell's character in the film he
doesn't really have it figured out he's
a smart ass a little bit of a deadbeat
and probably doesn't like himself very
much but even though he's going through
a hard time he never lost his Humanity
he was able to identify that a young kid
looked up to him and with that knowledge
he was able to make a profound positive
impact on him so if you're going through
a time in your life where you feel like
maybe you're not doing so well maybe
you're not qualified to help somebody
out of a bad situation I highly
recommend watching the way way back
because it will remind you that no
matter where you are in life you have
the capacity for good that's why you
can't buy into that you gotta go
your own way
my friend you're going your own way
everything I have learned
I will teach you
economics mathematics philosophy science
to read right
of course
when do we start The Count of Monte
Cristo this movie is so underrated The
Count of Monte Cristo is based on a
novel by Alexandre Dumas and it tells
the story of Edmund Dantes a man who is
wrongfully imprisoned and then seeks
revenge against those who betrayed him
The Count of Monte Cristo is the perfect
tale of betrayal and Vengeance the main
character Edmund Dantes endures the
worst torture imaginable and then
proceeds to have the biggest come up few
two things in life make me feel more
vicariously like a boss than seeing
Edmund Dantes float down on that balloon
in his party it's like come at me
I just arrived on a balloon this
film is highly inspiring it reminds you
that in life if you're stuck in the
prison of Chateau deep if you are
currently in Your Darkest Timeline you
can keep your head down and make
something out of it so that when you're
finally released from the prison you're
prepared you didn't use your hardship as
an excuse to waste away even though you
would have had every right to and nobody
would have blamed you isolation
loneliness captivity these things can
all be leveraged to your advantage
there's an upside to almost everything
but you have to find it by watching The
Count of Monte Cristo you'll be inspired
to transform even the hardest times to
your advantage The Count of Monte Cristo
will inspire you to strike at the right
moment and to have the strength to take
advantage of opportunity when it
presents itself because you've been
training you've been proactive it'll
also inspire you to go on an adventure
to find lost treasure and have the
biggest come up of your life and overall
just be an absolute G life is a storm my
young friend
you will bask in the sunlight one moment
be shattered on the Rocks the next
what makes you a man
is what you do when that storm comes
you must look into that storm and shout
as you didn't Rome
do your worst
for I will do mine
then the face will know you as we know
you
as Albert mondago
the man
[Music]
what happened to your feet
what do you mean these are my 407s oh
they're 407s can I see them yeah
yeah these offer a lot of support right
wow come on
what are you in a fraternity are you
insane are you in a fraternity you could
have hit somebody where was that that
I'm asking a question you have a
fraternity no are you Steve Jobs what
okay crazy Stupid Love Crazy Stupid Love
might sound like a weird one on this
list because it kind of is but it's
impact on me as a young teen was
undeniable Crazy Stupid Love is a 2011
romantic comedy starring Steve Carell
once again Ryan Gosling Julianne Moore
and Emma Stone and also Josh Groban he
makes an appearance he's got a banana it
follows the story of a middle-aged man
who after his wife asks for a divorce
seeks help from a young Bachelor to
navigate the dating scene basically the
utility of Crazy Stupid Love You know
you'll probably have your own takeaways
from it but my own takeaway when I
watched it for the first time is that
Ryan Gosling is a cool guy Ryan
Gosling's character in Crazy Stupid Love
was kind of my fashion and Charisma icon
as a teenager this film taught me to be
better than the Gap and to ditch my
velcro wallet
what are your wallet it also inspired me
to not be a bumbling doofus I'm a
cuckold to put more effort into you know
the way I dress the way I present myself
and just be a cooler guy in general but
the thing about Crazy Stupid Love Is
that Ryan Gosling's character isn't
without his flaws he's kind of a slimy
womanizer who has no soul which is the
nice thing about Crazy Stupid Love it's
a very human film I like the message in
this movie it'll get you thinking like
yeah you know what I should dress better
I should have some ribs I should I
should take care of myself but happiness
isn't found in buying things or using
people but rather in giving and in
sharing life with the people that you
love so absolutely take care of your
appearance because you're dignified so
you should reflect that dignity by the
way that you dress but to weaponize
aesthetic virtue to absorb pleasure from
others it's a vacuous behavior that will
leave you Hollow in the long run this is
what happened to Ryan Gosling's
character he used his Ryan Gosling looks
and style to take advantage of people
for his own pleasure and it left him
Hollow and profoundly lonely in the long
run whereas Steve Carell's character was
sort of on the opposite side of the
spectrum he loved and cared for his kids
but he sort of lost respect for himself
stopped taking care of himself
the balance is somewhere right in the
middle where you're not so self-absorbed
but you take care of yourself so that
you can increase your capacity to take
care of others because ultimately that's
what helps give life meaning
take care
elf okay guys hear me out elf is a 2003
Christmas comedy film directed by John
Favreau starring Will Ferrell it tells
the story of a human who was raised by
elves at the North Pole and travels to
New York City in search of his true
identity see okay elf it's not a great
movie I you know as a movie you know I
don't know guys he's an angry elf but
I'd be lying if I said this movie didn't
stick with me and that's because of the
Father Figure the father figure of elf
is the emotional heart of the movie he
sort of plays the straight man character
everybody can identify with the father
figure it makes you wonder what would
you do in this situation if this
absolute freak mentally unstable
man-child entered your life how would
you deal with it what if he was your son
like you don't have to watch this movie
it's not very good okay guys I actually
have like eight more movies in front of
me but I'm just running out of time to
talk about them so if you want me to
continue this series let me know in the
comments section below thank you for
watching
this video is sponsored by athletic
greens ag-1 makes it insanely easy for
me to make sure that I'm hitting my
nutritional goals out of all of the
multivitamins or supplements that I've
ever taken athletic greens has by far
the most complex nutritional profile
packed with over 75 vitamins minerals
Whole Foods or superfoods and adaptogens
in every single scoop ag1 makes sure
that you're giving your body everything
it needs to feel energized and focused
throughout the day my favorite thing
about ag-1 is that it's made from Whole
Foods so it ensures that it's extremely
bioavailable which means that your body
absorbs it very easily and you don't
just urinate it out like so many cheaper
multivitamins so if you're interested in
joining Me In by far the simplest way to
meet your nutritional needs then if you
use my link in the description below
you'll also get a year's supply of their
vitamin D3 and K2 complex which I also
have every single morning as well as
five ag1 travel tax with your first
purchase so once again make sure to take
advantage of that link below and thank
you again to athletic greens for
sponsoring this video